the LAPD confirms to ET that officers
have conducted a welfare check on
Richard Simmons the fitness guru who's
public absence is the focus of the
number one podcast in the country right
now has not been seen in public since
2014 the LAPD says it visited the 68
year old at his la mansion about two
weeks ago a detective tells as Simmons
was fine and quote there is no issue for
the police to be involved mr. Simmons
simply wants privacy that echoes what
Richard told us by phone a year ago no
one should be worried about me but it
made us wonder what life is like at home
for the now reclusive celebrity give me
that old razzle-dazzle during our many
visits to riches for million-dollar
estate in the Hollywood Hills you could
describe him in towards emotional roller
coaster you know what you have been a
big disappointment to me oh oh oh oh
this is the tough question let me think
Richard was often joking around that's
Richard in the kitchen in 2006 on his
computer emailing fans in his study in
1999 you can never get enough support
and dressing up and belting out show
tunes in front of his grand piano in
2011 everything's coming up roses
bridges former friend and massage
therapist Mauro oliveira painted this
colorful chair for Richard's house he
shared these photos with us but asked
that we conceal what he looks like now
Mauro says that when he last visited
Richard in 2014 he found him in bed at
two in the afternoon as a richer you
need to get up you need to eat you need
to drink water said no I just wanted
leave leave me alone there's one thing
we noticed during our last visit at
Richard's house before he disappeared
from the public eye this interview is
over he could be wildly entertaining at
one moment and in another melancholy and
fighting back tears when the King gets
depressed he doesn't call for his wife
he calls for the little man with pointed
head and he says to the court jester
make me laugh and I am neck or chest
[Music]